today on the matt wall show a generation
of spoiled entitled brats have decided
that they're actually oppressed even
though they've had
really the easiest lives that the world
has to offer
uh and that's why we've seen all this
chaos and destruction in the streets the
past two months
but normal law-abiding americans are
finally getting sick of it and
responding in kind and i think it's only
going to get uglier from here so we'll
talk about
all of that today also five headlines
including confirmation
from the government essentially that
space aliens exist
and the really shocking thing is that uh
nobody cares
just it's a it's we we've got better
things to worry about apparently
and in our daily cancellation we cancel
netflix for pushing the harmful
insane myth of transgender children
quote unquote all of that on the way but
first
the show today brought to you by
rockauto.com you know it's so much
easier uh
going to rockauto.com than walking into
a store
and having to you know provide all the
answers for all the questions they might
have for you
and then usually they're not going to
have the part you want anyway you just
have to order it online so why not cut
to the chase
you've got access to rockauto.com at
your desk in your pocket
and um that's what i do when i have car
trouble i go to rockauto.com i've been
going there for months and it's been a
lifesaver every time rockauto.com always
offers
the lowest prices possible and it's a
fair uh it's a family business too
so you know they've been doing this for
20 years doing it a long time very
honest family business best of all the
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low
and they've got that great selection go
to rockauto.com right now
you can see all the parts or parts
available for your car
truck remember to write walsh in there
how did you hear about usbox so that
they know that we sent you
okay now what we're watching play out
right now i think
is uh what happens when you take a
generation of people
instill in them an overriding sense of
entitlement
give them lives of immeasurable
comfort and ease grant them every right
and liberty known to man and even some
rights and liberties
up to this point unknown to men um but
then at the same time you tell them
somehow incredibly
that they are oppressed and that they're
victims and finally after
decades of this sort of schizophrenic
conditioning
you give them free reign to cause
whatever chaos and anarchy and
destruction they want
all in the name of justice of course and
the next step in that process
is the part that we're seeing now when
everybody else gets tired
of the madness tired of being held
hostage by these brats
tired of living in fear of the mob and
starts responding in kind and that
chapter of the story is just beginning
now it seems
and the next chapter will be even uglier
in fact it's only
ugliness preceded by even uglier
ugliness
from here on out unless something is
done to reverse the process or at least
to stop it from progressing any further
than it already has
what i want to focus on today though is
that entitlement you know entitlement on
steroids is what we're what we're
witnessing
protesters rioters who believe that they
are
invincible who believe they actually
have the right
the god-given or whoever given right
to shut down roads stop traffic
intimidate harass
assault burn loot pillage without
consequence this isn't a like a figure
of speech when i say they think they
have the right they really do believe
that they have the right to do it
now there were riots and chaos in cities
all across the country over the weekend
as usual
let me give you um a few examples of the
entitlement on display
by these people by focusing on on a few
incidents specifically all right
first uh let me show you this this is a
protester named julia clark
and she posted a long twitter thread
long and righteously indignant
complaining about a horrible evil woman
who had the audacity
to drive down the road the very road
that julia clark had decided was shut
down and if julia clark decides
that a road is closed well then damn it
it's closed and that's all there is to
it
and how dare anyone defy her so
uh here she is she says let me speak on
what happened in georgetown tonight
dc protest georgetown karen
tonight uh concerned of dc a activist
group apparently another one
because we didn't have enough of those
already led a siren slash noise
pollution protest where we blocked off
streets in georgetown
the police presence was heavy as we
blocked off streets we demanded that
people turn around
this was a minor inconvenience for this
affluent white neighborhood
you see how this is presented sort of
matter-of-factly
yeah we blocked off streets and demanded
that people turn around using the word
demanded uh which which i like the
thought doesn't even enter her mind
that perhaps she has no right or
authority to do any of that
it doesn't occur to her that other
humans exist
on the planet and that just because she
feels like it would be fun
and worthwhile to shut down part of the
city there may be other people who
strongly disagree with her about that
and that she has no right to impose
herself on those people and that in
trying to impose herself on those people
she makes herself into the aggressor the
the undisputed
bad guy in the situation none of this
occurs to julia clark
just doesn't even doesn't even enter her
mind uh here's more she says as we block
streets
certain drivers got annoyed and
attempted to maneuver their way around
us
this particular white woman tried to cut
through a gas station
me and a couple other protesters stood
in front of her car and demanded she'd
turn around
instead she steps on the gas and you can
see the footage there
um notice this uh this white woman as
you know
she's continually uh
described tries to go around them she
tries to cut through a gas station
but julia clark and her comrades are
incensed that this white woman has
defied her orders
it's she's she's not even in the like
she's not she's not actually going
through them she's trying to go around
them
but but but but julia says i don't know
you're not this whole road we've closed
how dare you
you can't do this we told you not to and
so they chase her down
and jump on her car and when the evil
white woman keeps driving
because she's scared to death now and
panicked understandably
julia claims that she's been run over
i mean she or or her friends whoever it
was
jumping on a moving vehicle and then
claiming that the vehicle they
jumped on ran them over
this is like that you know that scene in
fight club when edward norton beats the
hell out of himself
while begging his boss to stop beating
him
this is just like that and this thread
goes on for a while longer ending with
julia
simultaneously whining that the police
didn't come to her aid
and also saying that the police are
awful and she'd be defunded so
she's mad that they weren't there for
her yet she also
doesn't want them to exist at all you
see
it doesn't end there um let's let's
continue this tour of
maniacal entitlement this is a fun one
here's here's footage from
one of the protests uh this i
i'm not sure which city this is from
this is a young woman screaming in the
in police officers faces taunting them
and then reacting in in
horror when when they've when they
finally had enough watch this
get back
or effing what she asks and well they
answer i mean she asked a question she
got an answer
can't complain about that and notice how
her friends
scream in horror you know there's always
a woman if you know there's always a
woman in all these videos screeching
loudly in the background
because these tough scary antifa
warriors become damsels in distress
the moment someone kicks them in the
shins um you know one minute they're mel
gibson
in braveheart writing down the battle
line blue face paint
you know rallying the troops shouting
about freedom and the next minute
they're like my three-year-old crying
over a scraped knee
and asking for mommy to kiss his booboo
you even hear one woman ask in shock are
you serious
are you serious it's a revealing
question
and the answer is yes ma'am they are
serious see life is a game to you
clearly but it's not to those officers
and it's not to a lot of the rest of us
it's not to the businesses that are
being shut down or burned down or
vandalized
that are losing their livelihood
because of people like you okay for them
it's all serious
for you it's not because you're out here
you know you're out here uh uh you know
costume party pretending to be a
freedom fighter but i want you to stop
and consider consider the woman who got
herself escorted away by the police
you know she's up in their faces she's
screaming she's angry she's infuriated
about something
meanwhile she's a young attractive woman
in america
as such she has the easiest
life that the world has to offer any
group
okay i tell you this right now the life
of an attractive young woman in america
is by far the easiest for
any demographic outside of royalty
outside of royalty and political elites
and like billionaires
next best thing be a young attractive
woman in america
so why is she so angry like she's angry
at this what does the system ever do to
her the system loves her
the system will do anything for her but
nonetheless she's aggrieved somehow
because part of being entitled
is to feel perpetually aggrieved no
matter what all the time
even if there's no reason whatsoever to
have that feeling
and continuing the tour here then we
have
uh this person
[Applause]
you beat us
[Applause]
no further comment there is necessary i
uh
we'll move on back to the action in dc
um there's another activist who posted
this the cat the caption says
block the bridge and an old white couple
refuse to turn around like everybody
else so we'll keep them company
and then you see the footage of them
surrounding the vehicle standing there
they're bragging about intimidating and
harassing an elderly couple
this is something they're proud of and
they think people will be on their side
because
we as the people as the others in the
world
we as the world our only job in their
minds is to agree with them and support
them
no matter what they do the entire world
for them
serves no purpose but to provide them
continual affirmation
that as far as those people at the
protest as far as they're concerned
the only reason you exist the only
reason is to affirm them
in whatever they do so if you're trying
to drive down the road i mean that
doesn't matter what you're
you could be trying to get to work you
could be trying to visit a sick relative
you could have your your child in the
car trying to bring them to the hospital
doesn't matter none of that matters all
of that is secondary to
to their needs and their wants and what
they want
which is why they think nothing of just
every night just shutting down roads
they cannot imagine any reason a person
would have
to want to use that road that could be
um
that could take priority over their
reason for shutting it down
and by the way their reason for shutting
it down is they have no reason there's
no reason for any of this what's the
what what do you try what exactly are
you
trying to achieve by stopping this old
couple
from driving down the road like what
what did they do to you well we know
what they did to you they just they
disobeyed
that's the problem um now
that brings us finally to the story of
garrett foster okay this is all
uh really context and set up for
garrett foster uh a blm protester in
austin
who came out to the protest on i guess
was saturday
strapped with an ak-47 garrett and his
comrades were marching in the street
blocking traffic as usual
when suddenly the crowd became angry at
one car for committing the unspeakable
sin of trying to drive on the road
and so they ran and they swarmed the car
uh surrounded it
foster approached with his ak-47 and
moments later
he was dead foster was not the driver
the driver shot and killed him the
driver says that foster pointed the
weapon at him other witnesses garrett's
fellow protesters dispute that claim say
he didn't point it
i mean you decide who to trust here and
naturally of course the left has rallied
to foster's defense making him out to be
a hero
even though he's a white man with an
ak-47 normally the very picture of evil
uh according to the left but but but in
this case
they're all about it they they've
decided a great love
they've they've discovered a great love
suddenly for so-called assault weapons
and and he's standing in the street
aggressively approaching a vehicle
contrast that with the left's response
um to the couple that stood on their own
property holding weapons as protesters
walked by
those people were terrorists those were
domestic terrorists says the left
for holding weapons on their own
property garrett foster
is is is on the other hand a hero
apparently
for holding a weapon in the middle of
the street blocking traffic
so you can't hold a weapon on your own
property but in the middle of the street
blocking traffic well that's okay that's
that's totally fine
but i want to i want you to watch this
clip um
so that that's that's what happened
later in the night but
here's a clip from shortly before this
fatal encounter
um and this is a clip of garrett foster
being interviewed by someone asked about
why he's carrying an ak-47
listen to what he has to say tell us a
little bit about the gun again
oh it's uh ak-47 uh why'd you got it out
tonight
they don't let us march in the streets
anymore so gotta practice some
some of all right
[Music]
i think all the people that hate us and
you know want to say to us
[Music]
too big of a pus to stop and actually do
anything about it
why'd you start caring well our roommate
got arrested and they stopped letting us
march anywhere
okay so he says the people who oppose
him are quote
pardon the french too to do anything
and uh those are among the last words
that he ever spoke on earth
now there's a lot about this case that
we don't know and
i'm sure more details will come out as
time progresses but this should go
without saying
you have no right to block traffic you
have no right to swarm a vehicle
and if you do that with an ak-47
strapped to your body whether you point
it or not
you have nonetheless given the driver of
the car reason to fear for his life
so i say it again this should need to be
said
but it does you have no right to block
the street and swarm vehicles
how else can i explain this i don't know
how else to put it
it's very simple you have no right to do
it
this is not the first amendment the
first amendment does not give you the
right to stand in the middle of the road
and just decide what roads are going to
be shut down that night
and if any and if anyone uh defies your
orders to swarm around them beat on the
vehicle and do all that
you have zero right to do that if you do
it
you might get hurt if you do it in texas
you might especially get hurt
and when you do get hurt you have only
yourself to blame you were in the wrong
doing what you had no right to do
but going back to that clip of foster
speaking
he makes it clear that he wasn't
carrying the weapon because he feared
for his life
he makes that he's he's he's very
explicit about that no according to him
um the opposition are a bunch of wimps
he's not carrying it because he
he's worried about there's been threats
against his life or he's worried about
being attacked or something
no he says they're not they're not gonna
do anything he says
he was wearing it expressly to
intimidate
and he felt that he was invincible
untouchable
he's he's clear about that in that in
that clip
and he learned otherwise and he learned
the hard way sadly
um you know when you go around
trying to intimidate people
eventually someone might take you
seriously
so garrett foster was carrying that
ak-47 walking around intimidating people
uh it's all a game to him and he's again
very explicit about that he says ah
they're all a bunch of whims i got to do
anything
because that had been his experience up
till that point
eventually someone came along who was
going to take him at his word
um and i fear that there are going to be
a lot more garrett foster's out there
there are going to be many more people
learning the hard way
that they cannot go around behaving and
living as though the very planet itself
will stop spinning if they say so
the media and their democrat allies are
whispering in these people's ears
shouting more like encouraging them in
their delusional narcissism and
entitlement
but the rest of the country is tired of
it sick to death
fed up really and truly and
deeply and rightly outraged
um so i think there are going to be many
more wake-up calls yet to come
unfortunately
unless we put a stop to this all right
let's move on to our
um five headlines
[Music]
you know as we talk about all this news
uh by the way ben shapiro has a new book
out called how to destroy america in
three easy steps
that relates to you know everything
going on in the news uh
because it's uh it's a very impression
book the book covers
two fundamentally different visions of
america that are now on the table one
vision is unifying and finds our
unity and shared philosophy and culture
and history the other disintegrates our
country in the name of fundamental
change
how to destroy america three easy steps
details how this alternate world view
has gained so much culture
cultural ground so quickly and i'd
really recommend the book you can pick
it up on amazon
or at barnes noble right now number one
we begin with this
which you know to my mind should be the
top headline everywhere
uh it you know it really should have
been what i started the show with and
what every show starts with
a report in the new york times about the
pentagon's ufo program
okay this is this is some pretty
incredible stuff so listen to this
says despite pentagon statements that it
disbanded it disbanded a once covert
program to investigate unidentified
flying objects
the effort remains underway renamed and
tucked inside the office of naval
intelligence
where officials continue to study study
mystifying encounters between military
pilots and unidentified aerial vehicles
pentagon officials will not discuss the
program which is not classified but
deals with classified matters
yet it appeared last month in a senate
committee report outlining spending on
the nation's intelligence agencies for
the coming year
the report said the program the
unidentified aerial phenomenon
task force was to standardize collection
and reporting on sightings of
unexplained aerial vehicles and was to
report at least some of its findings to
the public within 180 days after the
passage
of the act okay uh let me get to that
there's there's a lot of
i recommend i rarely recommend new york
times articles but this one i'll
recommend there's a lot of information
in it
uh let me get to a couple of highlights
here
for more than a decade the pentagon
program has been conducting classified
briefings for congressional committees
aerospace company executives and other
government officials according to
interviews
with program participants in some cases
earthly explanations have been found for
previously unexplained incidents
um even lacking a plausible terrestrial
explanation does not make an
extraterrestrial one the most likely
astrophysicists say
mr reed harry reid the former democratic
center for nevada
who pushed for funding the earlier ufo
program when he was the majority leader
said he believed that crashes of objects
of unknown origin
may have occurred and that retrieved
materials should be studied okay now
here comes the part we should
you really need to listen to eric w
davis an astrophysicist who worked as a
subcontractor
and then a consultant for the pentagon
ufo program since 2007
said that in some cases examination of
the materials had so far failed to
determine their source and had led him
to conclude
quote we couldn't make it ourselves
mr davis who now works for the aerospace
corporation a defense contractor
said he gave a classified briefing to a
defense department agency as recently as
march about retrievals from quote
off-world vehicles not made on this
earth okay
there's the money quote right there it
only took me 15 minutes to get to it
so that is an astrophysicist who worked
for the pentagon
publicly confirming on the record to the
new york times
that they have retrieved alien
spacecraft that that's what he just said
in this new york times article that
strikes me as
like a pretty big deal
yet everyone is just like oh oh aliens
cool
aliens what else is on tv
uh there has been very little reaction
to this somehow
even though the pentagon the pentagon is
basically standing there and telling us
yes space aliens exist folks
we make a big deal out of everything
that happens in the world
except this somehow
now i i admit to that that i still have
a fair amount of skepticism even in
spite of this i fully admit that
uh because all you know all joking aside
well this isn't a joke at all but i do
have some skepticism even though i
believe that i certainly believe there
are intelligent civilizations out there
in the universe it seems almost
mathematically impossible that there
wouldn't be with a hundred billion
hundred billion galaxies and a hundred
billion stars in each of those galaxies
and you know trillions upon trillions of
planets i mean there are probably
millions of intelligent civilizations
it's just that the the distances as i've
always said the distances are so
vast that it seems likely to me that
that it's just impossible to traverse
them
or that um no civilization could advance
that far
within their technology without
destroying themselves first
kind of the cynical view but i think
there's something to that but even so
i mean this seems like a pretty big deal
anyways it's very interesting at least
and nobody cares uh but let's go number
two here
here's rather than caring about aliens
here's something that people did care
about this weekend uh
here's a clip that went viral watch this
and video games are a real problem
they're real problem you know why
because they're
fun and you don't yeah well i have a
real problem with them
and you you you do them and they're real
exciting but you don't get anywhere
right
it's like you could do like like martial
arts right you could learn jiu jitsu
you get obsessed by jiu jitsu and then
three years later
you're you're like an elite jiu jitsu
athlete you're like you're entering in
competitions you're a purple belt
you're moving up yeah you're doing well
you're thinking like i might be able to
open my own school one day that
confidence yeah if i have a hundred
students and those hundred students are
paying me x amount of dollars per month
i can make a living
holy [ __ ] i can have a this would be
amazing and then you see your jiu jitsu
school and your jiu jitsu instructor has
all these students and drives a mercedes
and he's got a nice family and like
that's the future this way you're doing
something exciting and fun
and you don't or you could just be
playing video games three years later
you could be that same kid
just playing video games waiting for the
next vics whatever the game is
you know next xbox game to come out and
you're gonna waste your time
people were extremely upset about what
you just heard there
from joe rogan because we live in a
nation of ridiculous stupid children
obviously everything joe rogan and he
admits that he's a video game addict
himself
okay everything he's saying there is
absolutely correct
he's saying that it's not good to spend
too much time playing video games
that's all pretty obvious really
undeniably true and he's saying that
you know if you look back at your life
he says three years you've looked back
at the last three years of your life
and you've spent hundreds of hours
playing video games
think about what else you could have
done
with those hundreds of hours
you know you could have become a jiu
jitsu master in the meantime you can
become a master of many different
disciplines and
and and and develop many different
skills
instead you just play video games and
you really didn't gain i mean
yes it's you you were able to relax
because you know that's
of course we're all just starving for uh
for relaxation and recreation right it's
not like we're
we're drowning in that stuff already but
okay it's recreation you were able to
relax you had a good time
that's fine nothing wrong with that i
don't think joe rogan is saying that you
should never play video games he's
clearly not saying that
but you don't really you don't this you
don't
you don't gain much else from it it's
you know you you look back on your life
at the end of your life and and you
think back all the time you spent
playing video games
you're probably not going to think to
yourself that was time well spent
right you're probably going to think to
yourself man if i could have just carved
out like a third of that
chunk it's like not not that i never
played them but maybe just
take a third of those thousands of hours
i spent
and used it to i don't know write
write the next great american novel i
mean anything become a master chef
right learn how to like build a house
learn how to farm
anything it's like an actual physical
skill where i'm out there doing
something
i mean i think that people people
probably think that to themselves
and that's that's a pretty obvious point
now
yes anytime this comes up the gamers out
there
will point out that oh well you could
say that about about watching tv you
could say that about spending time on
the internet
absolutely you could and people do say
that all the time i mean
how often have people lamented uh all of
the the hours that americans waste
watching tv and netflix and
and and you know trolling social media
yes
that that also is part of it but the
thing is
you're allowed to point out that
it's probably not the most constructive
thing to spend
40 hours a week watching tv you're
allowed to point out
that if you're on facebook for six hours
a day it's probably too much
like you're allowed to say that and no
one's going to cry about it
the only difference is that if you dare
say it about video games
people start crying which only shows
how right the point is and how necessary
it is to say it
because people take it way too seriously
and are way too attached
um number three before the national
anthem was played at a wnba game this
weekend
the players walked off the court in
protest here's the footage of that
anthem was played we saw the players
leave the floor go back to their
respective locker rooms
one of those actions we'll see
throughout the season as part of the
social justice
initiative yeah first of many ways that
we will see wnba plays
players using their voices all season
long this is nothing new for these women
they have been proactive when it comes
to speaking out on social injustices for
the life of the wnba
now as i understand it three of their
viewers were very upset
um and said they're not going to watch
anymore that's what i read
so the wnba just lost lost half of their
audience
which is which is a pretty steep loss
there pretty devastating
i guess you could say that this move was
not exactly a slam dunk
mostly because the players can't touch
the rim
but the really interesting thing is that
you know watching
that clip for most of us is the first
footage we've seen of a wnba game so at
least it confirms that the wnba exists
you know it's not a myth after all it
really is a thing apparently
i don't know why it exists but it does
uh it's just
out there you know if if women are
playing basketball in a forest
and nobody watches does it did it really
happen
you know that's been one of the
philosophical one of the great
philosophical conundrums apparently yeah
it did happen incredible number four
here's something uh we're starting to
see more of a political reporter posted
images from new zealand
showing that new zealand is basically
back to normal after covid and putting
them
in putting new zealand forth as a
success story due to their lockdown
policies and contrasting
oh look how well new zealand is doing
and you know the united states
look how poorly they're doing um and
then a dr
mike galsworthy followed up with his own
post saying no masks shaking hands
bustling crowds fully open economy
new zealand earned this by locking down
early and hard pursuing a zero coveted
strategy
libertarians would love to be in this
position but they are their own worst
enemies in a pandemic
now we're in a mess now i bring this up
just to show you
how dishonest our discourse has become
if you need it any more convincing
they're using new zealand as an example
crediting new zealand's success with its
policies
meanwhile new zealand is one of the most
remote populated land masses on earth
the entire nation has a population the
size of los angeles's
um it gets only about 4 million tourists
a year to the entire country
compared to 80 million for the u.s
it's an island its neighbor to the west
is australia 2500 miles away and
australia is one of the most sparsely
populated countries in the world
and its neighbor to the south is
antarctica
you've got a an island nation way out
there
um the furthest possible distance
you know for in relation to many other
countries and surrounded by ocean
if you go south you're in an arctic
wasteland
where the population is zero besides you
know whatever five or six scientists
living and living in
in you know research labs and then if
you go if you go
2500 miles to the west you run into
australia where you know it's like
there's people living around the coast
and just
nobody in the middle of that country at
all so
yeah i think probably that has a lot to
do with them
doing well in the pandemic new zealand
is going to do well in a global pandemic
literally no matter what its policies
are it doesn't matter
they're going to do well because they're
so isolated obviously okay number five
finally uh representative john lewis's
body
uh john you know john lewis obviously
died uh i guess was
over a week ago now or last week several
days
he was taken across so his his body was
taken across the selma bridge yesterday
um the time says as
as but here's the phrase take it across
the selma bridge
as remembrances continue
continue being the operative phrase
there there have been a lot of
remembrances
of john lewis um there was a memorial
service at brown chapel ame church
in alabama then another memorial service
at troy university in alabama
and then at some point his body was
ceremonially ceremonially brought across
the bridge
in a horse-drawn carriage with an
audience watching then his bo bro
then he was brought up to dc to lion
state for two days so the public can pay
respects
um then he'll be brought to atlanta
for memorial and then the following day
will be the funeral
okay so that's what three four memorial
services
plus couple other ceremonial things and
then the you know
body on display public and pay respects
then a funeral
all of this is happening while thousands
of americans have not been allowed to
to have funerals for their own dead
relatives because of covid
so just imagine i mean maybe you don't
have to imagine maybe you're in this
position
um i imagine someone
who was not able to have a funeral
service for their father who passed away
was not even even able to gather 20
people in a chapel for a funeral service
because they were told it's too
dangerous and yet now they turn on the
news and see
a politician has died and has
multiple funerals and memorials attended
by thousands of people across three
states
now if the funerals if the reason we're
not having a funeral service
for joe smith who dies down the street
if the reason his family can't gather to
mourn him
is because it's not safe
then it doesn't suddenly become safe
when a prominent politician dies
either it's safe or it isn't either you
can do it safely or you can't
if you can't do it safely then we
shouldn't be doing it for john lewis
if you can do it safely then there's no
reason why we can't do it for joe smith
this is obviously pretty clear cut
i would say now i don't have a problem
in normal circumstances with with this
sort of thing when a prominent
uh politician or dignitary dies and and
we have all the memorial services i
don't have an issue with that
you know um i know there are some people
that always raise issues with it because
they say house is you know
idolatry or whatever i don't see it that
way i think that this is
this is just what people do when when
when the prominent among them pass away
and that's fine i got no issue with it
um
but i do have an issue with it if we're
doing it
while also telling normal americans that
they're not allowed to
gather and celebrate the lives of you
know their grandparents and parents and
others
who pass away that that is just
that is a outrageous example
of elitism and you know rule
rules for thee but not for me type of
thing okay let's go to our daily
cancellation finally today for our daily
cancellation we are canceling
netflix over the weekend netflix had a
series of tweets written by
someone named rose demew a transgender
person hailing netflix for a recent
episode of the babysitter's club which
featured a quote
trans girl and it was of course very
nice of netflix uh to generously give
this transgender individual a platform
to talk about how great netflix is
so i i really appreciate that from
netflix and the thread goes through
all of the wonderful things about this
episode and as a
by the way as a big babysitters club fan
myself
uh i'm surprised i missed this episode
somehow i've seen the whole babysitter
series probably 10 times
somehow i didn't see this anyway so
let's let's go through
we go through all of the wonderful
progressive things that was
that you could you could could be found
in this episode and then we get to this
and the caption of this clip says when
bailey
the the male who we're calling a trans
girl comes down with a fever marianne
rushes her to the hospital
where uh two doctors misgender her mary
ann firmly corrects them
misgendering is traumatic this is one of
the baseline ways cisgender people can
show up for trans people in their life
um and then we have the clip let's let's
watch that clip
have you been giving him fluids if he's
dehydrated we'll need to place an iv
have him change into this i don't want
the blue one um
well i hear someone's not feeling well
let's take a look at the little man
can i please talk to you too outside
i know that you guys are busy but
as you would see if you looked at her
and not her chart
bailey is not a boy and by treating her
like one you are completely ignoring who
she is
you're making her feel insignificant and
humiliated
and that's not gonna help her feel good
or safe or calm
so from here on now please recognize her
for who she is
and if at all possible could you find me
a non-blue hospital gown
okay where to begin with this
first of all the acting here is just
tremendously bad
re and i i hold the babysitter's club to
a much higher standard than that
you know they're so i i'll never forget
the episode of baby search club when
samantha found out that becky
went to the mall with stephanie and
nobody invited her to come along
that final confrontation between
samantha becky and stephanie
and the monologue that samantha delivers
one of the great dramatic moments in
television history and a personally
life-changing
moment for me to witness this just does
not rise to that level sadly
there's a high bar for the babysitter's
club okay
um and this this this doesn't get there
so i'm disappointed that second of all
once again we see here the parade of
contradictions
that comprise left-wing gender theory
it's just nothing but
contradiction stacked on top of
contradiction
marianne the babysitter who's in a
hospital lecturing doctors about their
lack of lgbt awareness
while there are people with medical
emergencies who who need attention
but she's angry the doctors have the
audacity to judge bailey's sex
based on his medical chart and not by
looking at him
because if they looked at him then
they'd see that he has long hair and
he's wearing uh you know a butterfly
shirt and and that he likes pink not
blue
meanwhile leftists have spent the last
50 years telling us
that none of that stuff has anything to
do with being a girl
they're the ones who taught us that so
on the one hand we're told that there's
no real association between girl hood
and pink frilly things and that it's an
arbitrary
societal convention in fact a convention
that should be broken down and abandoned
uh and it never really meant anything
anyway to begin with
and then on the other hand we're told
that boys who like pink frilly things
are actually girls this is a
blatant and irredeemable contradiction
it's you you can't get around it
it destroys their entire narrative not
that they care of course but
it's it and i i have brought up this
point to um
many left-wingers to see how they
reconcile it
and they don't they can't they just
they they can't even address it
third if a child is traumatized by being
given the wrong colored gown
um that's a good sign that the child's
real trauma has nothing to do with the
gown
or what pronouns he's called
children in real life mostly boys
who are which by the way have you ever
wondered why that is
you know most of the time vast majority
of cases with the especially with uh
this is true in adulthood too but
especially with the kids
who come out as transgender almost
always boys
coming out as girls if this is just like
a naturally occurring
thing sometimes people are born in the
wrong body
why is it almost always boys that this
happens to
how do you explain that scientifically
well you explain it scientifically the
same way you explain any of this
scientifically which is you don't
um but anyway children in real life
mostly boys who are who are trying to
live as girls
and identifying as girls they are the
victims of trauma
and the trauma does come from being
misgendered so don't get me wrong when
when someone says it's traumatic to be
misgendered
i absolutely agree and i i take that
totally seriously
but the traumatic misgendering happened
when the adults in his life
told him he's a girl that's the
misgendering part
that's the trauma and now through no
fault of his own
he's living this false identity trying
desperately to maintain it
and anything that reminds him of who he
truly is
is now traumatic but only because
it reminds him of reality and it brings
him back to the to the to the real
trauma
the real abuse of having this false
identity imposed on him to begin with
and yes every single transgender child
has had that false identity imposed on
them
every single one without exception
because either you know when you've got
a young child
who's supposedly transgender there are
two explanations for that
either they have um they have hopelessly
progressive parents who push them in
that direction because the parents like
the idea of having a transgender child
that they can parade around and score
woke points off of
or and i suspect that's the case most of
the time
or the child is in that state because he
went through a perfectly normal and
natural stage of childish confusion
where he wanted to be a girl i.e he
wanted to play with dolls and wear pink
outfits because that's what being a girl
means to a child
you idiots when you've got a
four-year-old saying well i'm a girl
he doesn't know what that is all he
means by that the only thing he means by
that
is that he likes the things that he
associates with girls
do you know how i know that you know how
i know it because i could walk up to
any four-year-old on earth and say and
ask them a question
what is a girl and they couldn't they
couldn't tell me they don't know what
the word
actually means because they're four
years old
to them all it means somebody with long
hair
wears a dress likes playing with dolls
and many young boys will go through a
phase where they see that and they're
curious about it
and and it's it's attractive to them
okay
that's really normal
and if you're on the left you're the one
who said
you've been saying for 50 years that
boys can do all of that and there's
nothing wrong with it because all of
that is nothing but a societal
convention
if this is just a societal confession
how can his attraction to a certain
societal convention
tell us anything about who he inherently
is you're the one for 50 years that
taught us it tells us nothing
and now you're trying to go back on that
and say oh no actually it's it's it that
tells us everything about this child
um anyway where was i
yeah the the the way that this is
imposed is is either you just have
progressive parents that push kids into
it which does happen or
a a young boy goes through a very normal
phase
um says i'm a girl and uh and
the parents decide to just go with it
and they take the four-year-old child at
his word
they take his self-identity seriously
even though a four-year-old child has no
idea what he's talking about
when he says literally anything
have you ever listened to a
four-year-old speak they have no idea
that they're they're
they're not living in reality they're
they weren't they didn't even exist four
years ago
four years and nine months ago they came
into existence at conception by the way
not when they were born
okay but but less than than half a
decade ago they didn't exist on the
planet
they are very new to this planet thing
to this reality thing to this
being a person thing
yet they they you hear one of them
make a declaration about their their
inner identity and
and you take it seriously
well the parents that do that
you know are either
unbelievably stupid or insane
or they're they know better but they're
taking advantage of their child
because they want to score the woke
points or some combination of those
you know i suspect probably options b
and c a combination of b and c
insane and taking advantage um
[Music]
and that is the real trauma okay
that's the trauma that the child is
suffering from
and it is horrible and it is evil
and i i refuse
th this is this isn't not a hill that we
can abandon
to the left and just let them have it
this is a hill to die on absolutely
what they're doing to children let them
pretend
as they are taking advantage of and
abusing children and ruining them
pretend that they're the compassionate
ones and and
you know they're the ones who really
care no
uh so that's why netflix is canceled
and we will uh leave it there thanks for
watching everybody
thanks for listening godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
aoc whines about being insulted dr fauci
characteristically
misses the mark at the nationals opening
day and the government money printer
prepares to go burr once again
check it out on the michael knowles show